an update on the incident at Tewkesbury
School in gloucestershire and an adult
has been taken to hospital with a
suspected Stab Wound following an
incident at Tewkesbury School a reminder
the police were called around 9 10 a.m
today with a report that a pupil had
stabbed a teacher a teenage boy has been
arrested in connection with the incident
and parents or carers of pupils at the
school are being advised to go to
Dobby's Garden Center on Diamond Road
where police will be able to offer
assistance that update coming from
gloucestershire police and a reminder
that we mentioned earlier that the
leaders of neighboring school turbrook
school mentioned that police were there
as well just to keep everyone safe that
there was no cause for concern at their
school so that update there on the
Tewksbury School incident that a
teenager has been advised has been
arrested for a stabbing